so let's move on to our final speaker
um that is marcel vasquez chan latte
marcel are you online okay i see your
screen coming up
so um marcel is a php student
at uc berkeley and
in recent years there's been a lot of
interest in the machine learning
community
on algorithms to learn
representations of intent from
demonstrations
and particularly in fields like robotics
and
today marcel will tell us a little bit
about uh learning
formal representations of intent in the
form of formal specifications
from demonstrations okay great yeah
thanks sanjay um yeah so as sanjit said
um
this talk is going to be about trying to
infer formal specifications from
demonstrations and
this is kind of a series of papers kind
of combined together
and you know i want to make sure to you
know to attribute to the proper
contributions to the associate
ashish mark and sanjit um and so with
that i'm going to go ahead and get
started
so it's helpful here to think about a
motivating example
so you know if you could consider the
squid world where you have an agent
uh represented by this black arrow
that's its path um
acting in a you know potentially
stochastic environment and so it has the
following set of actions to move up down
left to right and their actions are
annotated on the grid
and with some probability you know we're
going to have that the wind maybe
uh pushes the agent down and so there's
some slip probability
and as sanjit said one of the
interesting tasks in this kind of domain
is the observation that even though you
know the agent may not have been
successful
you can try to ask you know what did the
agent try to do or what was the
intention
of the agent and so for example you
might ask naturally you know did the
agent intend to touch the red tile
if you think about this for a second and
you see that the you know the actions
are kind of inconsistent with that
hypothesis it tries to correct upwards
every time it moves downwards you think
you know probably not
and likewise you know there's this you
know if you think okay well
maybe the agent was trying to touch the
yellow tile and again you look at the
hypothesis space and
you think yeah probably actually the
agent was trying to touch the
towel while avoiding the red tiles and
so the main observation there is that
you can think of this
demonstration as kind of a form of like
a communication channel
where the age uh the teacher or the you
know the demonstrator
packages up this intent here you know
visit a yellow tile perhaps
and sends a demonstration and the job of
the learner is to kind of decode this
message
and so you know the idea is
the really interesting thing about
demonstrations as opposed to like
labeled examples is that you're able to
learn even in the case of unlabeled
demonstration errors
and you know in this example here you
know we didn't know
i don't have to tell you that this was
an error in order for you to kind of
guess that it's most like more likely
that you're trying to avoid red than not
and so the goal in this research and the
kind of the thread of this research
is to develop algorithms for learning
like formal specifications
from unlabeled demonstrations to see
kind of how far we can push that
and kind of a thing that we have to
address at the beginning this literature
really starts off in the robotics
community and
their rewards are the kind of the
typical paradigm and so it's helpful to
think about what are specifications
adding like should we just be learning
rewards and be happy with that
and just you know i'll very quickly
outline some
some problems these are kind of straw
man arguments but each of them can be
extended in more rigorous ways
so the first thing is to observe that
there's you need in some sense a form of
common currency in order to compose
rewards uh
so for example if you learn in a world
that you know you should reach the
yellow tile by giving a hundred
uh bonus uh to the agent and then in
another world separately you know using
another algorithm
you learned that okay you should
actually avoid these blue tiles by using
this demonstration
and you encode that using a negative 10
reward if i don't tell you
how what the exact transition dynamics
of this third world is where you put you
know yellowtail and the blue tile it's
very easy to construct counter examples
where you get this kind of perverse
instantiation of the
of the model and the agent actually
enters the
blue tile in order to reach the old town
and the second problem that we're kind
of trying to address with this
this literature is that you want to be
able to deal
in a very like at a very foundational
level with the idea of being
non-markovian
and so again you know if we have
something
where you have you know go reach the
yellow tile and now i want to add to
that after learning so i fixed
that concept and now i want to add this
ability to reach the screen tile if i'm
not careful
you can accidentally end up you know
maybe there's wind pushing downwards and
so this yellow tile is actually
kind of non-trivial to reach you might
always just stay in the green tile
and kind of the important thing here is
that it's not always easy to
make the system markovian because the
dynamic states are not the same as the
reward states and if you just naively
put all of the history
into the state space to do the kind of
natural extension
you you have to deal with this
exponential state-space explosion
and finally um kind of to
for this motivation is that we want to
be able to compose rewards as i said
and many rewards naturally compose
and you can using specifications you
know via conjunctive disjunctive or
you know temporal combinations you can
imagine learning concepts incrementally
or
parallel and then recomposing and then
applying some kind of synthesis
algorithm in order to
achieve your task
so the way this talk is going to be
structured is i'm going to first kind of
give a
kind of make sure that we are on the
same foundation in terms of what the the
problem is that we're trying to solve
i'm going to then give a naive problem
formulation
and that's going to be a reduction to
inverse reinforcement learning
then we're going to take a step back and
kind of figure out how can we exploit
the boolean structure
of specifications you know you either
satisfy you don't satisfy specification
and there's some
additional structure in there that's
right for exploration
and then i'm going to end with an
experiment if we have time so
the basic definitions um you know first
we're just going to assume we have some
finite set
of states and actions and so you know
here we have like a grid world and you
might imagine that that's a markov
decision process where the next state
only depends on the current state and
the current action and the trace here or
behavior
is simply just going to simply a
sequence of states and actions
and we're going to assume just for
simplicity and this can be pretty easily
uh relaxed
that all traces are the same length tau
and so specification in this context is
really just a trace property
and i'm going to say that you know you
trace satisfies the specification
if it is a member of that set
and the key thing is that outside of
satisfaction within that set
there's no operary order between traces
until i tell you the dynamics of the
system
you can't evaluate whether or not this
left trace is better than this right
trace
and importantly the agent model is what
induces the order
so you need to know you know what's
risky maybe there's a teleport tile here
that some probability warps you to the
wrong area
and you need to know kind of the agent's
objective and the agent's competency
so it's no good trying to infer what the
intent was if you have a you know very
incompetent agent
that maybe is just acting close to
random and if you
also changing the agent's objective also
will change your your prediction to the
to what the agent might be doing
so in that setting you know in that kind
of language the idea of a demonstration
as opposed to just a you know standard
labeled example
is that it's going to be an unlabeled
example where the agent
tries to satisfy the task and so you
know back to our
toy model the key is that you actually
have a notion of action in a dynamics
model in order to infer you know
was this conducive to to performing the
task
and in some sense you know and i really
appreciated um
uh the center's talk on on preference
learning yeah in some sense really the
preferences are coming
from the probabilities being induced by
how good or how successful this could be
so in order to solve this kind of a
problem there's kind of two components
that implicitly have to be
handled first we want to be able to say
you know is this more likelihood more
likely than the other model
and then the other question is you know
given a class
large concept class of specifications
you want to be able to search and ask
queries about the concept class
and just for time today i'm going to
focus on how we can come up with these
preferences like how do we know that we
prefer this specification over this
other abstract specification
and leave kind of the the searching
discussion for maybe an offline
discussion but i want to point out just
that
we've considered lattice concept classes
and and other variety and
they are learnable and you can kind of
efficiently search them but it's a
more detailed discussion so
let's get into the the problem
foundation and so
the basic schedule is going to be that
i'm going to cast the problem as inverse
reinforcement learning
you know there's a lot of literature
that's been developed for inferring
rewards from demonstrations and in
particular we're going to apply
a uh idea called the principle of
maximum causal entropy in order to find
a proxy agent model and so
just you know as a recap inverse
reinforcement learning you're going to
have a mark off decision process
so you've got actions um in states
determining the next states
and we're going to assume that the agent
is trying to optimize some unknown state
reward
so you know simply you're maximizing
you're finding some policy
that maximizes the expected reward and
your policy is simply a
you know a distribution over actions
given the current state
and the problem of inverse reinforcement
learning is then to ask
what reward what best explains the
behavior of the agent
but the problem with this kind of naive
definition is that it's not
it's not well posed you know if i give
you a reward that's constantly zero
all demonstrations look optimal and
conversely you know if i just kind of
tune my reward to be exactly
matching the the demonstrations then
again
everything looks optimal and so we need
some other way to disambiguate some
other way
to put in a proxy model and the idea is
to use the principle of maximum causal
entropy to do this in kind of a regret
minimizing way
so first let's talk about you know how
can we make sure we pose our problem as
inverse reinforcement learning so
we need some reward and you know this we
don't want an
any kind of gradient outside from our
our
our satisfaction and so the naive thing
to do and
kind of straightforward is to just use
an indicator so if you
are in the set of specifications you
know if you satisfy the specification
we're going to give you a reward one
otherwise you're going to use a reward
zero and it's not hard to show that this
is actually without
loss of generality you can use any two
variables you can use any two constant
values so long as both are not zero
so any kind of binary indicator
um but here you know we had to do kind
of a slight of hand
in doing this definition and we had to
lift our states to be traces
so if we had some small transition
system
and you know we wanted to talk about
specifications of length two
we're going to need this exponential
blow up in order to kind of define this
indicator
so you know this naive reduction you
know there's this exponential blob
but we're going to kind of postpone this
concern for now and leave it
later we're going to readdress this
because you know there's some nice
structure in the binary
formulation of this problem
so you know we now have a problem of in
casting
the context of inverse reinforcement
learning and now we're going to apply
the principle of maximum causal entropy
so the key idea with with the principle
of maximum causal entropy
is that high entropy policies are you
know robust
so the question i'm trying to ask in
order to get a likelihood of the
specification given the demonstration
is you know what's the probability of
any given action given the the previous
state sequence and this and the
specification
and the idea with the principle of
maximum entropy is that you can prove
that this
minimizes the worst case uh log loss so
if i
put in some other you know if the agent
is actually using some other
policy some other distribution here the
log loss is
minimized in the worst case if you use
maximum entropy
subject to feature matching so formally
the idea is going to be that we don't
want to over commit to the
demonstrations
and we do that by maximizing the
expected causal entropy that's
just the normal entropy kind of where
you sequentially reveal
the state sequence you you don't want to
be able to condition on the future
so you have to do this kind of variant
where you sequentially add
states subject to reward matching and
by that i mean just the we want the
policy that we ultimately end up with
to match the observed maybe expected
reward and with our indicator
really what we're saying is you know we
see some competency of the agent we see
some
amount of performance maybe they they
are able to satisfy the property 30
of the time we want to be able to you
know we want the maximum entropy model
that also has that performance and
that's what we're going to use as our
proxy model
and in this work i'm going to talk about
two cases
the first case is kind of the simplest
one where you
you know you assume that maybe this
causal entropy you don't really need to
to distinguish between you know you can
actually give all the state sequence
ahead of time
and that's what the action sequence is
and this happens in like deterministic
dynamics you don't actually need
the states and the actions are kind of
redundant
and then the second case i'm going to
talk about the more general reactive
setting
where you really have to distinguish
between causal entropy and
you know more traditional entropy so
let's start with the maximum entropy
case but before that
i want to kind of revisit this kind of
this problem that i
i posed and in order to kind of
address this it's useful to recast this
problem
as kind of a circuit so i'm going to be
operating in what's known as the random
bit model so we have a mark off decision
process
and we're going to think of this as a
deterministic transition system with
access to some point flips
so you can think of this as a dynamical
system we've got coin flips action state
next state and your dynamics then is
just just this function over
states and bits and what's nice
is that if you unroll you know we're in
the finite horizon setting so if we
enroll a finite number of times with
self-composition and then add a monitor
for the specification at the end
we just end up with some boolean
predicate
and so if we then add a policy to kind
of close the loop so we might imagine
that our
the boolean predicate what's important
to realize is that
you know you need to be consistent with
the bernoulli random variable you know
if you
forget the whole system and ask what is
just the what does the system look like
it just looks like a bias point
and that is kind of like the trivial
maximum entropy solution there
but then when you kind of take into
account what the the biases of the coin
is
there's really two effects the first
effect
is you know this environment bias so how
hard this
how hard the the dynamics and
specification are together
and then you have kind of the competency
of the agent so give an example
you know if we revisit our our running
example of entering the lava
if i remove the lava you know if i just
take away the lava from the world it's
trivially easy to avoid lava in that in
that dynamical system
and so that's going to bias the coin
higher likewise you know if i have a
very incompetent agent or very difficult
world
i'm going to have a bias that's lower so
you need to be able to separate these
effects in order to
to kind of talk about what the
probability of these actions would be
and so the main idea in the
in the maximum entropy case is that the
policy doesn't need to be reactive
and so these effects are actually
separable so
if we define piece of feed to be the
probability
of satisfying the specification under
our you know demonstrated
policy and we have q let that be just a
policy of you know
uniformly select actions you can show
and it's not so uh it's not too
difficult to
that the probability of the state
sequence given
the yeah
sorry this should be just the
probability of the states given the
world bottle and the specification but
the probability of that state sequence
is simply the
ratio of these two uh probabilities so
really you're just taking the ratio of
how much better than random
um is this agent acting and what's nice
is if in deterministic case
you know you can think of the
probability you're just selecting
uniformly at random this is just the
size of the set
and this actually recovers the science
principle from tenenbaum's
concept learning so the idea is that you
know essentially the harder
it is to just randomly generate a
specific uh uh satisfying example
tells you how you should adjust the the
the
agent's performance in terms of how
likely you think that that demonstration
is
so it's pretty straightforward um if you
add some additional modeling assumptions
like the
the teacher is at least as good as
random and the demonstrations are id
and that your demonstrations are
approximately representative so the mean
is roughly what you would expect to be
to be given the newly random variable
then
you know what's algebra you can kind of
reformulate this as the probability of
the demonstrations given the
specification
is simply you know you have this
threshold that encapsulates being better
than random
and this information gain over random
actions
and you know if you've taken a course
information theory this is just a
reinterpretation
an instance of sonoff's theorem so you
can think of this as your probability of
the demonstrations
is just you have a channel and you're
asking how atypical are these
demonstrations
under the random action hypothesis so
it's kind of a nice result but in
general you know you can't do this and
it's
that's really more like we just have a
standard information channel
and in the principle of maximum causal
entropy you have to actually account for
the fact
that this is a you you only have delayed
feedback you don't know about the future
before you apply an action
and so you generally need to be reactive
and so here you know when the agent
actually fell down
it applied a corrective action to avoid
the entering the lava and so we need to
take this into account
in our model so
you know i'm gonna kind of state without
proof um
and you can check the this is really
from uh z bart's
brainzyme thesis um that the principle
of maximum causal entropy kind of
implies the soft belmont backup
on the policies and so you just want a
your policy is going to be exponentially
preferring these high value actions so
the q
is considered the value of the actions
and the v is the value of the states
you're just going to exponentially bias
your actions towards high value
and you kind of do it via this recursive
update where you either give this
boolean
zero one weighted by some theta and or
you apply some
soft what's known as smooth maximum or
log sum of exponentials
in order to you know estimate the value
of the current state
and the idea is that the maximum entropy
policy
uh given p star is the one where you
match theta to match p star
so you know if i just kind of quickly
focus on the soft value calculation and
we
like i said replace that log sum of
exponentials with smooth maximum
you can think of this just as a variant
of the standard bellman backup in
in markov's decision processes where
you've replaced smooth maximum with
maximum
and if you think about this on the
unrolled structure you can think about
this as a computation graph where at the
leaves you know you have
zero and then one all the areas where
you satisfy specification
you've got theta and so you're trying to
match uh
you're trying to tune data to match the
satisfaction probability
but the problem is you know the you need
to somehow search this efficiently
and what's nice it's is that the smooth
maximum and expectation
kind of uh collude in a way that the
satisfaction probability
is growing monotonically in this this
parameter so it's sometimes called the
rationality so how
how close to optimally rational your
agent is and so it's zero it's acting
uniformly random
and infinity it's it's agreeing with the
optimal agent
and so because of this monotonicity you
can show that you can
binary search for data in order to find
this this fairly efficiently
but you know we can't directly work on
the structure because it's growing
exponentially
but if you kind of take a step back you
realize that
the these rewards you know there's a lot
of shared structure a lot of this tree
is
really redundant and the system and
environment actions are ordered you know
you have to go in a particular sequence
so the intuition the insight was to
encode this as a binary predicate and
that's what we you know we previously
established actually that we can write
this
as a binary predicate and so if you
write the
the binary decision diagram in a
particular sequence of uh
bits so you have your actions and your
points and your next actions and your
points
you can take this uh binary system
diagram
and you can compress uh you can write a
compressed representation of the
dynamical system
and then we'll show that you know you
can actually do the bellman backup on
this causally ordered bdd
and the basic idea and i'm going to skip
over this looking at the time
is that the the bdd because of the
associativity of smooth max
and expectation and kind of that they
operate kind of nicely on
identity means that any skipped edges or
any kind of
actions that have been split up across
bits you can actually work
directly on the bdd and interpret the
computation
graph directly so that's kind of a nice
result
and you know furthermore using the
standard circuit bound from
binary decision diagrams you you know
corollary of that is that you can
this bdd is going to grow almost
linearly in the horizon
and quasi linearly in the actions um
you know this you're you know you have
to pay a price for every point bias
point that you introduce
and then you're going to have a a
representation of like the minimum state
uh the minimum state representation you
need in order to monitor
this uh this property
you know but importantly you know linear
in the horizon and in principle you can
compute this using function composition
you starting at the beginning of the
horizon and just incrementally enrolling
the bdd
so i mean that's the basic algorithm for
for you know the entropy maximum entropy
case and the maximum causal entropy case
you know you
in the maximum entropy case you need to
be able to compute the performance of
random actions and this is in some sense
just weighted model counting
and in the compressed and backup you're
able to also operate on the on a bdd and
it's
not quite a way to model accounting but
has a very similar flavor
of combining um kind of models in a in a
very
strategic manner and so
using that those insights are able to
kind of assign
likelihood preferences between different
specifications
given a series of demonstrations and
then using additional
structure on the concept class you're
able to you could be potentially able to
search the
for the most likely specification also i
think we should wrap
up yeah so i'll i'll skip over this
and uh the main point of the experiment
is we
we we tried this out on a small toy
example that's based off the running
example you've seen before
and you know there's some demonstrations
that slip that's this red one is that's
actually an unlabeled negative
demonstration
and the main observation is that the
true specification
is in this kind of model is actually
still more likely than all these
consistent specifications despite being
you know unlabeled and so
uh you know if you want to look at this
later it's you can actually run this
experiment this link
um but the the main conclusion that i
like to you know the main message of
this talk is that demonstrations offer
kind of a natural way to relay a trace
property
in a manner that's very different than
what you've see what you see typically
in like standard membership queries or
equivalence queries
um and you're able to you know depending
on the concept class able
to learn even given unlabeled
demonstration errors
and you know we sketch two algorithms
based off of the principle of maximum
entropy and maximum causal entropy in
order to do this
and with that you know i can conclude
and if there's any other questions i can
kind of use that use that time to fill
in any gaps
thank you okay thank you marcel are
there any questions from the audience
okay let me kick things off here so um
can you
um what have you thought about
generalizing the approach to
uh non-trace properties more general
kinds of specifications
so like hyper properties or yeah
in the general case hyper properties
or even things like invariants right um
they don't they're not necessarily trace
properties
yeah so in the the main problem with
uh within variance is how you extend the
extend past you know the current point
so invariants are necessarily infinite
uh horizon properties and so we've
worked on this
uh i remember we discussed this a little
bit i think susan and i when i was at
sri but i don't think there's kind of a
the maximum entropy uh definition kind
of suffers from some issues that it's
really
only well defined in the finite horizon
case and so
when you start getting to infinite
verizon you need to make additional
assumptions on how you constrain that
the randomness otherwise it can blow up
to
an arbitrarily high quantity so um
i don't i don't really have a nice
answer for that setting
okay there's a question on the chat uh
what is your intuition on generalizing
your approach
to the continuous state space so
continuous state spaces um
so actually so that my backup that i
that i showed
in some sense you can you can imagine a
situation where you like take this this
tree and then at some point
there's a sub tree that's continuous
right and you can summarize
that whole quantity using a particular
value
and this is actually what's done in
what's known as like the soft actor
critic model
so you can imagine that this whole
really what's important in the
continuous setting is to be able to
estimate
these kind of soft values um things are
a little
you're able to as long as you're willing
to mix the
the relative entropy like the continuous
relative entropy like the normal entropy
everything
kind of works out um so if you have like
an rrt where you
you expand to part of the state space
then that whole subtree is
some other continuous extension um as
long as you're able to
estimate the relative entropy uh it
should work out but that's uh
i haven't tried it so
all right i don't see any other
questions on the chat or q and a so
uh thank you marcel and let's thank all
the speakers again
thank you all for a very interesting set
of talks and and a great session
um and i think that's it for today and
so uh
we'll see all of you back again a week
from today
for another session of the synthesis
workshop
bye